topics and some recent work on them um
so the first will be copy protection
uh so so copy protection
um
for programs really the the goal is to
prevent someone from you know getting a
piece of software and and sharing it
with all their friends uh you know
classically this is a typical way we
would have done this is by
having verification codes or something
like that
but at the end of the day a program is
just a sequence of ones and zeros and
you can
classically anyway and you can copy this
as much as you want so all of these um
unless you're actually going to require
like the program interacting with an
online server or something like that if
you want a completely offline program
uh really at a fundamental level
classically there's nothing you can do
to prevent someone from copying your
software everything really is just a
roadblock
um
so there uh before jumping into the
quantum world there is a classical
half solution to this problem which is
something called water marking software
and the idea is just just like
watermarking a picture where you you
know you put the
you put some watermark like your
property of mark zandry um and
with a picture watermark what is the
goal the goal is that if you were to try
to remove
the the watermark the picture's
destroyed and not really worth anything
so much the same way we can hope for
um watermark software where there is
some mark embedded in the software that
people can can detect
um
and and yet
uh there's no way to remove that mark
without just completely destroying the
functionality of the software
um why does watermarking maybe help with
uh you know protecting your software
from being copied well if i give you um
some software that's watermarked with i
don't know some some private information
about you that you don't want to get out
uh well
you are probably going to be hesitant to
try to release your software to your
friends because uh your friends would be
able to read the watermark and see that
they're you know to learn learn whatever
private information you might have
or if it has your home address and um
you know one of
some watermark software's floating
around there on the web and the law
enforcement gets their hands on it
they'll know who who leaked it and who
to go prosecute
um so so watermarking software uh works
as a deterrent
to
uh piracy but it's not it doesn't
fundamentally prevent it um right you
know you still could copy your program
as many times as you want send it to all
your friends there's just an incentive
not to
and what we uh
oh well before i get into that um i
should say that we we have a lot of
results positive results for
watermarking um sort of similar to the
case of obfuscation that um we talked
about in the morning
um the positive results tend to be
more or less only for cryptographic
functionalities
um
there is also evasive functions
sometimes but you know more or less or
most of the results are are for
cryptographic functionalities and really
the reason for this is is maybe maybe
not so surprising um it's that we're
like a lot of like especially this work
here a lot of these works actually used
io so you know you're
like you're you're using techniques that
are sort of limited to obfuscating
cryptographic functionalities so maybe
it's not a surprise
um
there are there are things beyond um
what we can you know beyond obfuscation
like there's this notion of trader
tracing that you can kind of sort of see
as a version of watermarking for
decryption functions and this we can
actually do with with much better foods
and i'll i'll note that uh for
watermarking
um unlike for obfuscation so remember
for officiation we said it's it's
trivial for learnable programs
it's interesting for a whole host of
programs including evasive ones
for watermarking
it's actually impossible for learnable
functions right because if i give you
program code that uh compute some
function but maybe has a watermark
embedded in it
well i can query that code on a bunch of
inputs of my choice
certainly that's what it allows me it
allows me to do at least that
and if it's learnable i can learn the
original program from just oracle access
to the program and that allows me to
construct the original unwater marked
program
so
you know we went from something that for
obfuscation was trivial to it actually
being impossible for vulnerable programs
um and then it turns out that it depends
on how you define uh watermarking
exactly and there's certainly some some
versions where evasive functions make
sense so sorry it's very
so yes saying that it's impossible
for learnable functions according to
some definition yes
but if you count queries or something
like that maybe it's not impossible
uh yeah except for like there's no
uh
sorry it's impossible it's a strict
sense but yes
look at the amount of resources that it
could be
yes
to learn the function versus to remove
the watermark then you could you could
get into a fine-grained sort of uh
setting where yeah like it's technically
possible to remove the watermark but it
requires you know it requires a year of
computation to do so about a year but it
requires more queries uh
uh well no because once you learn the
function you've removed the watermark
that's right but it takes some amount of
work to learn the function yes
and versus takes a lot of work to remove
water oh and you're just saying that
those should be
closed that removing the watermark is so
is as hard then
in some sense you're in good shape
yeah fair enough fair enough um
yes yeah so i you know and i'm not
really giving formal definitions anyway
um i'm thinking of the usual way we
define things where it's you know for
all ppt adversaries as an inevitable
function in that regime it's impossible
for learnable functions uh but yeah
certainly you could say interesting
things in sort of a more fine grain
so the watermark is something that you
would insert into the code that has no
effect on the input output uh
that's what you would hope for that's
not possible it turns out yes
i mean it would be hard to find it would
be hard to find yeah so okay so you do
change the input output you do you do
and that's inherent um at least assuming
i o exists so if i o exists then um you
can take any
uh
if i o exists and you had a watermark a
supposed water market seemed to
perfectly preserve the functionality you
could just io that
and then that doesn't have a watermark
anymore
so the the way that all these approaches
work the you know this approach based on
obfuscation and even in the trader
tracing setting um you it's
what you end up doing to embed the
watermark is you change it on a very
sparse set of inputs
and the idea is that you you also need
that those like those smart sets of
inputs can't be distinguished from like
inputs you would care about
um
and then and then you sort of use the
outputs on that in order to
um yeah and i should also say so so with
evasive functions it's a little more
nuanced it depends on exactly what kind
of watermarking you want but in general
for for exactly this reason um evasive
functions are
will
you know you can take them as being
unwatermarkable as well
because for an evasive function you
expect on most inputs for the output to
just be zero so how are you going to
meaningfully embed a mark in there
undetectably
if yeah it's just only zero
okay so
so then um erinson proposed uh using
quantum information to prevent copying
in the first place
by setting your
program code to be a quantum state and
then the hope is that you can use the um
unclonability of general quantum states
to conclude that you can't copy the the
program code
sorry but i still want to insist on this
about
i mean we really want this
uh i i'm mentioning water marking it'll
also be relevant in a bit but i'm
mentioning water marking just because
there is a classical solution that does
something to prevent piracy um and but
it really only serves as a deterrence it
doesn't actually prevent you from
pirating it just says if you pirate uh
you will be it can be detected i guess
what i'm saying is what kind of software
do you want to learn
is it the kind of software that has
something to do with security or is it
kind of soft and has something to do
with data
and ownership you see this ideally we
would want to be able to watermark
anything but we don't know we only know
how to prove
uh
watermarking schemes for cryptographic
certain cryptographic functionalities
but ideally you would want you would
want to call you would want to protect
any software that you might come up with
whether it's cryptographic or not
um
that holds true in the water marking
setting it holds true for for quantum
copy protection which i'm about to talk
about
um
but the the fact is that you know sort
of because
it's related to the fact that with with
obfuscation we don't know how to offer
skate programs
if the program is a function and you've
just told me that it's impossible for
learnable function then you're saying
that you can only hope to watermark
things which are cryptographic financial
uh
i mean
maybe maybe
if you take cryptographic generally to
mean something that's non-learnable sure
um but like maybe uh
uh what would be an example um
maybe i have a fast algorithm for
multiplying matrices or just i want to
protect
my operating system or something like
that
um i don't know if if these are
um
you know so certainly like an algorithm
multiplying matrices fast
is uh
i mean maybe that doesn't fit into this
framework anyway
um
you can't you you can learn
you can learn that as multiplying
matrices but you can't learn small code
but but that's not the regime we're
talking about anyway so that was a bad
example
um but but you know thinking about an
operating system or or you know some
some complex piece of code that is maybe
doing
uh
very complicated computations but
they're not they're not
by definition they're not like it's not
like i'm trying to build a suit on a
function i'm just trying to build a code
that does something functional um
sorry that's it i'm not asking
but i think that the example of the
matrix multiplication is a good example
so it's it's working really fast right
and you don't know how
and somebody wants to say that that's
their propriety idea but the input
output is just you put in a b it comes
out eight times right and you can't
measure time there's no side channeling
right right so that's a good example
from that perspective but it's a bad
example from the perspective of we're
we're not paying attention to we're not
paying attention to sort of polynomial
differences
where you know there's a trivial
algorithm that's not watermark for
multiplying matrices which is just you
know the grade school algorithm
okay
there's no advantage in that algorithm
from the vague vague setting that i'm
thinking about
um okay so
so what we what we want though is to use
quantum information to just
prevent you in the first place from from
copying the the program code
um so there are there are some
challenges so one is uh oftentimes if
you're if you're the class of functions
you want to copy protect is rich enough
um it'll actually imply quantum money a
public key quantum money so for example
if if you're trying to copy protect the
signing algorithm
you could just test whether it signs a
random message or not as your
verification of the quantum money state
and that will be publicly verifiable
so you know to get copy protection in
many settings not all but in many
settings we're
we're sort of stuck at this barrier that
um we're going to have to
imply quantum
publicly quantum money which you know we
we said in the morning was
non-trivial uh also
a random function
uh not necessarily because you need to
be able to verify the outputs that's why
signatures yeah okay
um
so another problem is that it seems to
apply off escalation so
this is this is informal and vague but
um
you know if if you could figure out what
the program what the
program is doing from looking at your
quantum state
uh you could you know maybe maybe you
could just write down a
uh a classical code for that and just
send that and copy that as much as you
want so it applies some form of hiding
something about the way the program
works
um
and then lastly there's just there's
still this issue of you know even though
we we know how to do obfuscation we know
how to do quantum money uh at least from
strong enough tools how do we combine
them together to
uh
to actually
you know get what you want so quantum
money there's no functionality right
quantum money just does it verify or
does it not we have the we have some
functionality and we want the
functionality to be on how do we like
combine these different
and these are
uh and then also note that copy
protection is for the same reasons as
watermarking it's
trivially impossible for learnable
functions
um it does make sense for evasive
functions
um
but yeah for
for learnable functions if you could
learn you could you you could just take
the quantum state learn from it the
classical code and copy it as much as
you want
okay so what's known um
so
so aaronson proved uh
back in 2009 that it exists
unconditionally relative to a quantum
oracle so by quantum oracle i mean that
the oracle's actually providing a
unitary um
[Music]
and then we improved this
to it exists relative to a classical
oracle so this is an oracle that
implements a classical function but
you're going to be able to query it on
superposition
um and then you know somewhat uh
on the negative side anonymous showed
that
um actually
not only are
[Music]
learnable functions impossible but
there's actually some non-learnable
functions for which coffee protection is
impossible
and
this result here and both of these
results what they say is that for so
certainly they're not saying that you
can copy protect uh learnable functions
but they're they they show relative to
an oracle that you can't cop or that you
can copy protect
any function that is non-learnable
um but what this result shows is that
when you try to
instantiate that oracle either of these
oracles with any real-world structure
that security will fail at least for
some programs that there are some
classes of programs that even though
they're non-learnable
and therefore not trivially
therefore you can't trivially copy them
you can nevertheless copy them um
yeah yeah there's an assumption here you
need uh
you basically need uh well you need like
quantum fhe basically
how are the penetrator without stated
and they say invisible or non-memorable
functions
oracle or
yeah how are the physical literature
stated like you say for all
non-learnable functions they can be copy
protected yes so the first two results
say for all non-vulnerable there it
exists in oracle relative to which for
all non-learnable functions we can copy
protect those functions relative to
oracle
um
but then yeah so this result then says
that uh
you know even though you you have this
result relative to an oracle um there
you there's no hope of instantiating it
in full generality with any standard
model objects
um that there will always be some
functions that are non-learnable um
which
according to these theorems you could
copy protect but now once you
once you move to the standard model
you can't copy protect anymore
um and you know this is it it's sort of
it's analogous results uh it's more
complicated but now gives result to
obfuscation so right relative to an
oracle you can dbb office skate
you can get ideal obfuscation for any
any circuit
rather easily
but once you
once you instantiate your obfuscation
with any actual um real world structure
the barak at all impossibility says that
there are programs that you can't
obfuscate
and it's you know it's the
the impossibility here is kind of the
same idea but you have to work harder
now that there's quantum information
involved
yeah so i mean uh
yeah i'm not
really rigorously defining learnable but
what i mean is what i when i say
learnable i mean that
um
right that there is an algorithm that
makes queries to the functionality and
is able to find their program code
and
yeah i will allow the
learner to make quantum queries
um okay so so what what what the
anonymous plocker result says is that we
we
really
don't want to use these you know super
complicated oracles um to to justify
security because we don't we don't
necessarily know what it means um once
we move to the real world
so um then there have been some more
recent work
um so here colo dengelo and all what
they showed is that using random oracles
you can get um copy protection for a
certain class of evasive functions with
some security um it turns out it's not
the i won't really talk about
talk about this result but it's not the
kind of security you want it's like it
basically says that they're
in some sense that there's no way to
like perfectly copy but there there's
still some room here to maybe like
approximately copy
um your your functions
um
and then uh
a little more recently
we we showed that using io and various
quantum money techniques
uh and quantum money techniques and also
techniques from the obfuscation
literature that we can get copy
protection for certain types of prfs
certain decryption functions um
something called signature tokens
um
and so
uh and i should say that when we
published our results it was we had to
make an information theoretic conjecture
in addition to assuming io and then
kolfin vitic later approved our
information theoretic conjecture
um
so uh
right so this this is kind of the more
or less the state of the art so just
like with obfuscation just like with
watermarking we we now know how to copy
protect
uh
you know certain cryptographic functions
um we also know that it's impossible for
for certain functions
um but you know we still don't really
know
uh how to copy protect you know general
programs um
that may or may not be you know prs
decryption or
signing algorithms
um
so i did want to talk about a special
case which i find super interesting
um so so it's something that's called
unclonable encryption and it doesn't it
doesn't immediately look like copy
protection but it you can sort of view
it as a special case
of copy protection
um and even here even for unclonable
encryption
uh which is a really a really
natural simple object already the
problem is very seems very challenging
there's a lot of interesting questions
here
um so what is unclonable encryption so
we it's a it's a secret key scheme
so we imagine that that alice has a
secret key k
she she has some message and she
encrypts it to get a ciphertext c
um and we're
we'll think of m as being classical but
c is going to be quantum
right and then uh
an adversary gets its hands on on c
and what is the adversary going to do
the adversary is going to try to split
the ciphertext into two pieces
c1 and c2
and give them to some
two more adversaries i'll call them b
and c
um and then b and c actually later learn
the secret key k
um and okay so so one thing
one thing that can happen here is our
adversary a gets the cyber text they
forward the ciphertext to say c down
here and they give nothing to b
in which case c once they learn the
secret key can decrypt and learn the
message
but b learns nothing
and essentially what we want is that's
the only thing you can do that no matter
what the splitting adversary who doesn't
know the key is whatever no matter what
they do to come up with two ciphertexts
and the c1 c2 they might look like val
ciphertex they might look like you know
total nonsense um but they split them in
some way into c1 and c2 no matter what
they do
essentially
all that ends up happening is one of the
users might learn the message and the
other the other adversary learns nothing
so what why is this interesting well the
the original motivation of gotzman was
that um
you you basically wanted
to know if someone stole your
information so if you if you encrypt
some message
and then an adversary was able to um
you know like steal that that encrypted
message from you
um
and then you know maybe the adversary
through some other means learns the
secret key maybe it gets compromised in
some way
well you would always be able to tell
if an adversary stole
the cyber text from you because if they
did if they were able to steal the cyber
text in some way that allowed them to
learn anything about the message you
would know that encryption on your own
device must fail because you can think
of you know your own devices is be here
um you know modeling it as an adversary
makes it only strictly stronger um and
here's the the remote adversary that
stole your your data
so the fact that so if you're here and
if you're able to decrypt your
ciphertext you automatically know
that um an adversary here that may have
excel traded some of the data about your
cyberx you immediately know that they
actually
couldn't learn anything about your
message even if the key was later
revealed
um yeah so this was the original
motivation of gotzman and then broadband
lord said well why don't we just make
you know
all these parties an adversary
uh
right and um
there's sort of a informal connection it
is a little more formal but um i i'm
hesitant to make any concrete claims
about one implying the other
but
basically
one-time
secret key unclaimable encryption can be
thought of as copy protection for point
functions
right
so so why why is that well if you had
copy protection for point functions you
could set your point to be your secret
key
and then you could copy protect
basically the
the function
that um that identifies that one point
and and outputs the message if it
identifies it i guess here we
technically need a point function
outputs many bits
um and you know go and it kind of goes
both ways if you if you had a one-time
symmetric key
on clonable encryption you can view the
ciphertext as an obfuscation for the
point function
that takes us input the key and outputs
the message m
uh right so so really really um
one-time symmetric key on callable
encryption can be thought of as just a
special case of copy protection
uh so what do we know um so broadbent
and lord showed that uh
you know a bit a really basic scheme
kind of based on you know why there's
quantum money scheme or bb 84 you know
kind of the natural thing you would try
to do
um
satisfy some form of security
um
something that i believe it's their term
but certainly i would call it
unpredictable unpredictability security
which sort of says which sort of says
that the the two adversaries can't
simultaneously learn the message except
with negligible probability
um it's not as strong as what we'd want
so it could you know with their scheme
it could still be that you know each
adversary learns some piece of of the
message
um but they just can't both
simultaneously learn it
um and then they they they strengthen
their scheme
using uh random oracles but there's
still so it's still a rather weak form
of security
um
okay so here's here's their scheme it's
basically just the quantum one-time pad
uh so you know if it's just encryption
bit by bit in every bit uh you you
either flip the bit or not based on on
part of your key k1 and then you encode
it in either the computational basis or
hadamard basis based on a bit of
k2
right and and what did broadbentlord
show exactly they show that no split
state adversaries can simultaneously
predict
um a random message uh so if the message
is random
both the no split state adversary can
have the two atmospheres b and c
simultaneously predict m
with probability more than this point
eight five
number point eight five to the n which
uh you know this is i forget the what
the constant is a half plus
one over like a constant that comes up
in the monogamy of entanglement games
but certainly if we got a stronger
security requirement so if they can't
learn any of this so then that wouldn't
be satisfied right because we could make
it so that the first one can learn the
first half of the bits and the second
one
would be like that right because you can
it just because it's encrypted bit by
bit you can just separate the bits of
the two pieces yeah exactly right um
so we wanted to fix that then we would
you have to do so you have to do
something you can't do bit wise
encryption right you have to do
something more successful
you say random and m you knew the
probability of m
to be zero was three quarters then
it's only if it's 60 50 m
that's what they that's what they
analyze um i'm not sure if
um
[Music]
yeah i'm just i'm not sure uh what you
could say
certainly m has to have um
it has to be pretty it has to have a
pretty substantial amount of entropy so
you you can't you can't get uh
like worst case like we would like in
crypto where it's you know m is either
m0 or m1 so instead it comes from a
distribution but i i was wondering if
you mean really
i mean every single sentence
theorem relative to the entropy of it
there there is i i believe there's a
generic if m has high enough entropy um
uh
i i don't know what how high it needs to
be but if m has high enough entropy you
can sort you i believe you can
generically get sort of a you know a
looser bound here
just like encrypt a random
extract from it yeah so great great um
so i'll get to that in one slide um
so i you know the other thing that we we
just talked about is that there's also
uh
right so there's a split attack where
you can just because you're encrypting
bit by bit you can just take you know
some set of the bits send it to one
adversary some set of the bits send them
to the other adversary and it's easy for
each adversary to learn you know their
part of the message and we would ideally
like to prevent this
um and even
there's even a harder problem um i mean
it's not harder but a different problem
which is even if you know but let's say
both adversaries just cared about the
first bit forget forget everything about
the first bits um you you can even do
something that you you would you
wouldn't expect
um here here's a really simple attack
basically what so our adversary a who
gets the original cipher text what
they're going to do is they're just
going to guess
which basis you use for say the first
bit they're you know we're throwing
everything else away just focusing on
one bit they're going to guess what the
basis is
and they're going to be right with
probability of half
at the right well they don't know if
they're right but they're going to
measure the ciphertext in that basis
and if they guess wrong they're going to
get random garbage but if they guess
right what they're going to get is
actually
um m but uh you know xor with the
appropriate key bit
so then
what the adversary is going to do is
they're going to send
the measured bit i call it a d
and which basis they guessed
to
this is a classical value now right so
they can send it twice
and then the adversaries are going to
say well okay if um
if
i now the there says b and c they know
what the basis was they know if a
guessed correctly or not if a guessed
correctly they can both uh decode and
learn the message
if they if a guest incorrectly then they
then they give up and say okay i'm not
going to learn the message
what this means is for any i
um the
parties b and c are able to
simultaneously unambiguously
learn both mess learn the message bit
um with probability of half and this is
just something that you wouldn't expect
to happen
um in sort of uh you know an ideal
scheme where you can either send the
ciphertext to one or send the to the
other
there's a little more sophisticated
attack um that actually gets this .853
to show up um so when i say unambiguous
it's because you know when you were
wrong as you get this bot
um
but you can actually do a different
attack where where you don't know if you
were right or wrong but you can actually
exceed a half probability and you can
actually get the probability that both
parties simultaneously guess
the right message bit to be as high as
0.85
and uh yeah this is just you know if i
was only sending the bit to one party
and and the other person learned nothing
one party learns a bit with probability
half or with probability one the other
party learns a bit with probability half
so there's no way to get the 0.85
um so
right so so the scheme gives us a rather
a rather weak
uh guarantee about uncountable security
okay so you know the
the next natural idea is why don't we
um use the fact that we get some sort of
unpredictability
and then extract from that
unpredictability uniform randomness
using an extractor or even better yet
let's just throw a random oracle and
random oracles are fantastic extractors
um so how are we going to encrypt now
this was also in broadband and board
what we're going to do is we're going to
choose a random string x
we're going to encrypt x using the the
scheme from the previous slide and then
we're going to use x as
a seed or not a seed as a as a source of
randomness for an extractor
and use the extracted value to actually
export a message
um
right so
so um i won't really get into the the
details
of this
but um so broadband and we're able to
show that this does get you better
security um but it's still not all the
way to what you would want um
it's
uh
right instead of this .855 it's
something much much better but it's
still not this ideal notion of either
b gets the message or c gets the message
and the other party gets nothing
and actually it turns out
that uh
that you just you can't do that with
this scheme so with this scheme
you cannot actually get the optimal
security notion it it's it's not at all
trivial to see this um i i don't have a
great intuition for
uh you know like if you were just to
look at it i don't know that there's
like a nice explanation for what goes
wrong
um
but it turns out that they're
you know even with this you know this
extractor notion was like sounds like it
should make sense
uh it turns out that you can't prove
security and one of the sort of
conceptual difficulties with using an
extractor here
is that oh so one we need this extractor
to be secure against quantum site
information okay let's not worry about
that that one you know there's been
literature on that
but the other one is that we're we're ex
we're extracting
um
from a string that one of the parties
knows and the other party doesn't know
or you know we're hoping that one of the
parties doesn't know
um but it could actually be that like
each party b and c each of their view of
the string x actually doesn't have men
entropy
right like think of the adversary that
gives the ciphertext to b with
probability half and gives a ciphertext
to c with probability of half um so
uh and then if if you're given the cyber
text you decrypt it correctly if you're
not given the ciphertext you just make a
random guess
so um
from each adversary they have a
probability of one half of guessing x
correctly
uh but
uh extractors require a lot of
minitrophy
right you need you need to be able you
need x to have an entropy conditioned on
your view that's greater than the length
of the string you're trying to extract
but our main entropy is only a half
so
there's
you know you could try some sort of
thing where you you try to condition on
which party is able to extract or not
but it turns out that when you when you
when you try to do stuff like this it
just doesn't it doesn't really work out
and and i guess it's for it it turns out
there's a reason it doesn't work out
it's
that the scheme actually cannot be
optimized
um
like what kind of attack is always
allowed
uh
yeah so so what they show roughly
is um so there's this concept of a
density matrix that generalizes uh pure
states to to look at probability
ensembles over states
um
and and basically so i i'm sort of fuzzy
on the details but they show that if if
that density matrix has high eigenvalues
then
this does have high eigenvalues um
that's as much as i can say about it
because i'm not too familiar with the
details
um all right and it it uh i don't know
if it gets worse exactly but there
there's another barrier here
um
which is which was to me very surprising
um and it says that if you have a
deterministic scheme and we're talking
quantum so we have to be a little more
precise about deterministic so if you
have a scheme where the transformation
on the message is unitary
um it can even be a little more general
than unitary maybe you pad your message
with the zeros and then apply unitary
transformation but the point is it's
reversible and deterministic so if you
run
if you run it on the same message twice
you'll get literally the same state as
the output
um
if you want such a unitary scheme
and you wanted to have statistical
security
you have no hope
um
and i i found this quite surprising
because on the other hand like with
ordinary encryption even if you're
encrypting quantum states or whatever
you know if you want one-time security
you actually can do it statistically and
deterministically right like in the in
the classical encryption setting we only
introduce probabilistic encryption as an
asses as a necessity when dealing with
many times security
uh and if you're only having one time
security you can get away with
determinism and you can even get away
with statistical security but it no
longer holds here
um and this this again it's a little
hard to give an intuition for what's
going on but basically even if you apply
a random unitary to
your your message which you know a
random unitary would require an x
dimension of the bits to even write down
but even if you apply a random unitary
to your
state in order to encrypt it there
it turns out that there's like an
information theoretic attack that would
allow you to
um
right and so then we we uh we go on to
give a positive result
uh that actually uses the subspace
states again
uh and the positive result sort of
circumvents this issue in two ways one
it uses random coins so it's not a
unitary scheme and also it uses a random
oracle so it's definitely not
statistically secure
we can't even prove it under
computational assumptions
um
and and what's the scheme it's uh
it's sort of a natural
i'd say the hard part here was proving
anything um but the scheme is sort of a
natural um generalization of
the the broadband large scheme so um
what we're going to do is we're going to
use subspace states except they're um
they're a little different
and we call them coset states so instead
of having your
your x
uh instead of having um your values go
range over the subspace they're gonna
range over the coset of the subspace so
the coset is defined by s
and also we're going to put a complex
phase in here
this
x dot s prime
s prime basically is going to represent
the coset for the the dual apert
um
right and what's what's nice about
uh
these coset states is that if i perform
the quantum fourier transform i actually
get
i i get the i get another coset state
where i just it's you know instead of a
it's a perp and instead of s s prime is
s prime comma s so just
for a fourier transform replace a with a
perp and it exchanges the rules of s and
s prime
so how do i copy protect
a
uh a message
or sorry not public effect um
vulnerably encrypt
so my key is going to be a subspace
and then i'm going to choose my co-sets
at random
at encryption time i'm going to choose
my close sets of friends so importantly
these are not part of the secret key
and then i'm going to give you the coset
state as part of the ciphertext and then
i'm going to extract from sms prime a
random string or you know a
pseudo-random string that i'm going to
use to encrypt them
right and uh you know there's you know
some details here because sns prime
uh
you basically need there to be a unique
representation unique representative of
every coset
um that you act that you actually hash
here because the hat function doesn't
know anything about the the subspace
uh
right and so how do you how do you
decrypt
well if you know a and you have the
and you have the subspace state you can
extract s and s prime
um
without much effort
and then you
once you extract s and s prime you hash
them down and you accelerate the message
or x cipher text
um
[Music]
right so so you know this this is now i
guess the the state of the art but it's
uh it's still rather weak right it's uh
it you know okay maybe needing random
coins isn't the big deal but it's still
in an idealized model we only know how
to prove it in the random oracle model
we don't know how to we don't know how
to replace h with a
computational assumption like uh prf
or
um or even like there's no there's no
real reason to think that you couldn't
do it information theoretically with
[Music]
independent function or extractor or
something like that but this is what we
know how to prove
and uh i guess where the random oracle
comes in is it helps it like very easily
helps us go from
uh you know if you can't if you can't
compute s and s prime then h of s s
prime is actually random in the random
oracle model
we don't have such a strong extraction
property for standard model functions
what's happening like compare these to
the local result of buy-ins at all
like
what's that like why do we manage to get
the securities in here
yeah so so really what it has to do with
um
yeah again i don't have a great
intuition for for their results but
um the reason the reason
that i the way i think about it is
where
this subspace state sort of starts off
already not being bit wise right you
know there's like all this entanglement
in the subspace states
and it allows us to make much stronger
statements about
uh
you know the hardness of finding these
cosets than kind of the analogous
statement that you would get from just
doing things bit by bit
you know it's it's it's maybe like very
loosely related to the fact that like
the
um
you know the weisner quantum money
states or you know bb-84 or whatever you
want to call it the you know the
unentangled bit by bit states they don't
make a good quantum money scheme with
public verification um even if you were
somehow able to like give a an oracle
that could verify that oracle would
immediately break the scheme or here the
oracle doesn't immediately break the
scheme and
we utilize some something like that in
order to justify security
uh
okay so
um i guess this is
sort of open question number four now
is can we can we build uncleanable
encryption or or you know roughly
equivalently copy protection for point
functions in the standard model with
provable secure
would a you know could you instantiate
our our scheme with an appropriate
extractor and prove that it works or the
pseudo-random function or something like
that
uh with or without computational
assumptions just something in the
standard model
i mean we have a bunch of candidates for
how to do quantum copy production
yeah yeah but with with provable
security relative to like some
assumption cryptographers
yeah like even even even io uh
we don't know i mean my proposal from
2009 was just
you know pseudo-randomly you know
encrypted or something and then just
treat the output as a description of a
quantum circuit to be applied to the all
zero state okay now just treat that as a
fingerprint of the string right
and then just go go and test that if
someone has any other
right right so i mean one
um
and one subtlety i'd have to look at it
i'm not sure that the definition that
you prove necessarily is actually
equivalent to unclonable encryption
but what's happening
yeah but but uh well but my claim is
that the right notion of security for
copy protection for point functions
is probable probably very close to
unclaimable encryption but but even that
aside um yeah so so certainly you could
you could you could nevertheless
conjecture that your scheme um satisfies
this or the follow-up scheme with the
classical oracle
um
but you know appropriately instantiated
i mean right i mean i have no idea how
to prove anything about it but i would
be astonished if that didn't give
whatever you needed right right right uh
yeah so the question really boils down
to i mean
but i i
if you would ask me uh
if you had asked me three years ago or
even two years ago i would this
astonished me
um the fact that the fact that this this
is like the most natural thing that you
could
you you would expect this to work you
know you have something unpredictable
you extract from it you get
pseudorandomness and somehow it doesn't
work um
uh
so i
you know i'm not that confident one way
or another but um
yeah so
but yeah get it with provable security
it's even relative to io
but combine i o lwe i saw it in these
lpn anything you want uh you know
construct unclonable encryption with
optimal security
relative to that i mean
i feel more confident in the inability
of someone to find the structure in the
random quantum circuit than they feel an
io yeah fair enough
yeah i mean i guess the
you know what we're
you know as cryptographers we like to
um
you know rely on the history of an
assumption having been analyzed by a lot
of people um rather than and you know
maybe eventually random circuits will
will be the assumption that we use
um but you know even as of now even
though io is questionable and a lot of
people in the computer don't like it it
still has had more eyeballs i think
okay uh yes it's even open information
theoretically it's possible yeah it
could be informative you could you could
have an information theoretics scheme as
well um for all i know for all i know
you can take uh you can take our scheme
and make this uh
you know an information theoretic
extractor for all i know
like i mean for an information
theoretical copy production scheme if
the error probability were small enough
then you would just try it out on every
single input and then you had made
copies of that way right right right so
the so so so so it can only work if
you're willing to tolerate in our
probability that it's like or you know
or another way to say it is that even if
you had a an information to your enemy
secure scheme if you then just have like
like a
many copies of the program then that
then it would become information
theoretically and secure
right right i i'm having trouble a
little trouble mapping between the
unclonable encryption and copy
protection in the unclonable encryption
setting it's a little more clearer i
guess um
uh but yeah and copy protection yeah
well i mean all i'm saying is that if
you have enough copies of the program
then you know you could just take the
majority vote of all the programs on
your input yes
if our probability is small compared to
two to the n then i just try it out on
every input and then i find my secret
and you know and i know
no possible information theoretic
security right right i guess the the
sense in which uh i don't need to go
back the sense in which this is
equivalent to copy protection though is
is really only in the one-time setting
where you're getting one
one copy protected version of the point
um
right so yeah i think i think if you're
going to go to
many times you probably need
computational security because yeah yeah
which also shouldn't be a surprise from
like viewing it as an encryption scheme
many times secure secret keen script
encryption also requires computational
assumptions
the one time setting it could be
unconditional for all i know it could be
unconditional
uh all right
so
i guess
uh
yeah i guess i just wanted to mention
that there's a relaxation called copy
detection or what i call copy detection
which is basically we're not actually
preventing the adversary from cloning
but we want to be able to detect if they
copied it's sort of closely related to
watermarking
but there's no deterrence here it's just
you know if the adversary is able to
copy one of these things
both of these may be able to compute the
program but one of them won't look right
and you'll be able to tell that it's uh
a bad program
um and it turns out we we actually made
the connection to watermarking explicit
if you could copy if you could watermark
a program with um public watermarking
meaning you can move it appropriately
you can also copy protect it how you um
you set the mark to be the serial number
for
um a quantum money scheme and you give
out your watermark software and your
your banknotes
so you know this is classical the the
watermark software's classical so i'm
not preventing you from copying the
functionality
but if you copy it
only one of your copies will actually
contain the valid banknote
um
and because because it says you know we
watermarked the software where the mark
is the serial number the only way to
sort of
present a valid program
um is to actually present a valid bank
node relative to this
so so there's this nice connection
between
this weak form of copy detection
and and watermarking so we can just you
know automatically use any quantum money
scene you want and any
uh watermarking
any watermarkable
set of programs and you can you can then
copy detect it
uh who knows if we can upgrade sort of
this blueprint to
um the copy protection i don't know sort
of inherently only in the detection case
um and then
uh around the same time in anthem
laplace they they constructed something
called secure software leasing which
i'll talk about in one second
um which i in my mind i think of a
slightly different and i'll explain why
i think about it slightly different from
copy detection
but they they also use quantum money and
some other standard tools to get copy
detection for a different class of
functions
um
[Music]
okay so so that's copy protection
i'm just gonna very briefly talk about
revocable cryptography so this is the
last
um area so the idea here is
um you know alice gives bob some quantum
state that maybe does something maybe
it's a program that computes some
interesting function maybe it's
cryptographic i don't know
but then at some point alice wants it
back
and you know bob then
does something to convince alice that he
you know either destroyed the program or
actually handed it back to her and once
he's done that and alice has you know
verified
uh that she has the right program back
or at least that you know just
verified some proof of destruction now
bob shouldn't be able to run the program
anymore um
so so so revocable cryptography is
really kind of a relaxation of um
quantum copy protection in the sense
that you know alice
uh
you know if
if the way that bob gave the program
back was to actually give a program that
that you know evaluated the right
function
then the fact that alice has a you know
al can check the program check that it
does the right thing
and um if it succeeds she'll be
convinced that bob couldn't still have
the program around otherwise baba would
be breaking copy protection
so some sort of relaxation
yeah i mean so alice doesn't have the
have the ability to actually like tug it
back
uh that that's not going to be possible
but
yeah so he could misbehave and not give
her anything which case he still has the
program can still run it but um if he
gives it you know maybe he gave alice a
deposit or something and he wants his
deposit back after running the program
um alice wouldn't give the deposit back
unless bob gave her a functioning
program but the point about the analogy
condition is that once he let's say
decides to do it back
he really he does not have it anymore
correct correct
rigorous sense
right so okay so here's secure software
releasing um and just uh so you can
think of it as copy detection except one
of these programs requires a secret key
to verify so it's sort of like
uh
right so um
[Music]
right so we had we you know with copy
detection we had these two programs and
anyone could tell that
uh
or one of the two must be must fail
verification and the verification is
public for both programs secure software
releasing is sort of this weaker version
where this
this one up here only has to pass a
private verification algorithm this one
has to pass the public verification
algorithm
um so this you know basically this is
the this is the uh program that alice
expects back from bob she you know knows
all the secrets involved in the program
so she's able to do the private
verification
um but someone else um
someone on the outside would be able to
do the public verification
and um anatomy
showed under under standard tools that
you can
do this for a certain class of invasive
functions
there's also this the this recent
concept that's emerged called encryption
certified deletion where
you have a
you know the adversary gets a cipher
text and then at some point gives a
proof that they destroyed the cipher
text and you want that if they give you
a proof and it actually passes that um
even if the adversary later learns the
key they can't learn the message or ever
any info about it wait wait wait but if
the
the the message was classical
information that they all had that the
anniversary had full access to then it's
impossible in principle
uh
i mean they they they always could have
saved a copy somewhere well but the
adversary didn't know the key when they
had to destroy the cipher text
right so that
okay
so the adversary only gets the key down
here at the end at the beginning they
don't know the key
and mainly and is the thing that they
hold at quantum state
yeah okay so so c is a quantum state
the the proof may or may not be quantum
um
so so
so they held this quantum state and now
they're going to prove that they no
longer hold it right which you know
indeed they can do if it is by a
protocol that involves giving the state
to someone else
if the state could be verified yes right
right so so not hard observation is
actually unclonable encryption gives you
this uh it's not it's not quite trivial
you do have to work for it but what's
this
they could show the government that they
what what's this
k is the secret decryption key
so i don't understand the story so i
sent you a copy
so
these are the quantum cipher text
and now
uh pi is the suppose that i destroyed it
yes
and k is what
k is the decryption key
no no you you destroyed the cipher text
not the key
why do i want the key if i don't object
well maybe maybe it gets revealed later
like maybe you have leaks later for some
reason or or gets exfiltrated somehow
from from the honest person server so
carry something that i only get if i if
i destroy it
not not necessarily right right the the
point the the it's a way to model the
fact that you actually destroyed your
cyber text if even if you were given the
c
at the end you you can't learn even
sorry even if you're giving k at the end
you you even if you're given the key you
can't learn the message like that
that really says you destroyed the
cipher text because if you had the
cipher text you'd be able to learn the
message okay okay so it's a definitional
thing
yeah and you could probably come up with
some scenario where it makes sense but
it's a definition okay right
you don't have to send an error you're
saying even if i had the k k i should
not distinguish now between
um
yeah and uh
yeah so so unlike unclonable encryption
we can actually you know we actually do
know how to do this uh in the
statistical one-time setting
uh so there's a one-time secret key
setting um and then in this recent work
um the authors
uh showed how to use cryptographic
techniques
so i have a question so this is like uh
reminds one immediately of deletion and
rightly forgotten this kind of thing
you're saying that's possible at least
in this setting where you define it as
an encryption
right
yeah
yeah i mean it's it's sort of most
natural for cryptographic objects to
think about um
you you could certainly ask if you can
prove deletion of of some
entries of a database too i don't know
if there's any
hope of
getting um you know like a strong
cryptographic kind of security
definition
for for like a general data set
it could be distinguishable from whether
you had it to begin with something like
that
right but i guess the the the problem is
you know like with with some sort of
data center data structure um
you know certainly if you if you have
the
feasibility of actually seeing what the
data structure is you can just write it
down as classical bits and then you can
you can destroy it but you still have
the data around so it's really sort of
inherent that something gets hidden
in order to have any form of security
here so it's kind of most natural to
talk about it as an encryption scheme
um yeah and i just want to mention um
one other one other work and it's maybe
it's arguably the first work of this
like revocable cryptography
um
well so it's due to unruly 2013 but so
the idea is okay so in the classical
world we have this object called time
release crypto
um
where i i encrypt the cipher text
there's no key for the cipher text
but it takes a long long time to decrypt
uh you know maybe a day or a week or a
year or something
um
and you know these are constructed based
on
certain assumptions about repeated
squaring and groups
and
so unruh had the idea of well why don't
we why don't we make it revocable so
you know i i give you the cipher text
now it's a quantum state you can start
working on it um you know spending your
week or whatever whatever the desired
timeline was in order to get the message
but then um you know someone says hey
give me that ciphertext back you give
the ciphertext back and you want that um
now you know even if it was five seconds
before you were gonna figure out what
the message was you you can't learn the
message
um
right so he defines his milk notion of
revocable time-released encryption
and the construction idea is exactly
what you would expect it to be
it's um
you do a classical time release
encryption of of a random key and then
you do uh say some encryption schema
certified deletion you encrypt them
under under 15k
um at the time no one had no one was
talking about encryption certified
deletion so he he actually had a you
know specific protocol for encryption
but this is kind of the intuition for
um
for
what what to do and the idea is that um
you know if you if you delete this
um you know five seconds before your
time's up
then um even though you eventually
finished the finish computing here and
learning the key k well you don't have
the ciphertext anymore so you can't
learn the message
it turns out getting the security proof
to work is actually non-trivial um
you know again it has has to do with
this combination of quantum information
theory concepts and
um you know proving things the way we're
doing cryptography of reductions and
stuff like that
uh getting getting the security proof to
work is not doesn't make it's not a
generic con
conversion like i wrote it here you have
to sort of open up this encryption
scheme and
it's a non-trivial proof but
another example yes i've done all the
work i'm like it's almost at the last
step yes still get it revoked to go to
the beginning or just to get the story
completely just completely
it's not like you slow me down again you
could imagine that too but no the way he
was thinking of you just you just lose
it completely
no matter how how much computation you
did no matter how close you were
um once once it's revoked assuming you
actually partake in the revocation
um you lose the ability to
ever learn the message
um okay so
uh
i know i'm over time but there was one
so that completes sort of the overview i
did just want to mention that there's
another really exciting area
um which is getting uncomfortable and
unclonable cryptography with classical
communication and that this
i know to me this was like amazing that
this could even be done um if you think
like oh i have unclonable states
uh i want to do interesting crypto with
them i have to do it via communicating
those unclonable states but somehow
amazingly we we now have some techniques
for getting unclonable
crypto with with classical communication
um
and
uh
yeah i don't i don't know if i want to
spend too much time on this
but
um
this was just some sort of
intuition for how this might be possible
uh
but okay maybe i'll just skip that since
um but
uh so this kind of all started with this
work of proper schedule
who
gives this
proof of quantumness
assuming lwe and then you know so the
proof of quantumness isn't really an
unclonable cryptographic object but
no cloning was sort of inherent in in
their um
in their construction
and
uh
and it's since been those ideas have
been used to build um say public key
quantum money um
and the dream goal is actually going to
be publicly verifiable quantum money
where all the communication is classical
communication with the bank
communication with the other parties so
to send a banknote it's classical
this would be the dream goal we don't
really have a satisfying solution to
this um in the private key quantum money
setting there there is a solution by
radian and sata all right
and then in
the public key setting we we can
actually have the bank be classical so
the minting process
is classical so the the bank can send uh
banknotes banknotes just using classical
information to people
but then when people want to go spend
their quantum money they have to
actually
and i guess i should have maybe
mentioned my own work we reconstruct
relative to an oracle
um publicly you know the publicly
verifiable quantum on possible
communication
um the question is how can i say
using one class communication and they
finally appear somewhere else yes okay
um yeah and the the the the rough idea
is that you can use interaction so so
certainly i can't if i have some quantum
bank note
and i want to give it to you and i send
you just a classical string
if that sent the banknote you could just
do whatever protocol you're using to
reconstruct the bank note on your end
you could just run it many times and you
you copy the state but um using
interaction it turns out that uh you can
uh you can actually put in theory do
better um
and and the
you know i don't want to spend since i'm
already over i don't want to spend much
time on the slide but basically like
what what um alice can do if she wants a
banknote is she can she can generate a
quantum state locally send some
classical value that's you know a serial
number some sort of digest to that state
the mint signs it with a signature and
then her quantum money state is you know
whatever her state was together with the
signature from the bank
um
and then you know if this quantum state
itself has some sort of signing ability
then she could send the banknote to bob
using some sort of similar process
that's kind of the gist of why this
might be possible with with interaction
um
right so yeah this this is uh
you know my last
uh big open question is can we throw any
cryptographic assumption in one but
standard model no oracles so io lwe lpn
exogenes multivariate quadratic whatever
you know any anything that's been
conjectured in crypto
uh
and studied by
you know a reasonable number of people
assume that can you get
um
get publicly verifiable quantum money as
possible
and that's that's it that's the end of
my talk
i i could mention i just want to
advertise my goal one of my most
annoying or open questions in this area
can you get publicly verified upon money
relative to a random article
right yes that's a great question um
yeah so
you know i
i thought briefly that my
quantum advantage stuff from yesterday
make anything of it
um
but yeah you know so the yeah the the
point i guess is that everything we have
for building quantum money seems to
require a lot of structure like it
requires these subspaces or you know the
knot scheme is in variance in montagne
there's all the structure going on can
you do something without structure
um
um